I'm Matt Korver I'm the creative
director for King's Quest we're really
impressed with the cast that we ended up
pulling off for this lab so he wouldn't
let him back into the tournament with
something as a stoppie as a dragon's eye
I'm playing King Grail and the new
King's Quest I kind of felt I knew the
time which I'd love to do if I'm going
to do it I'm Tom Kenny and I do the
voice of the merchants of miracles in
the King's Quest game no time to lounge
my boy lucky for you the parade is
halted
another case of a mysterious missing
bridge I imagine the thing about the
merchants of miracles is once in a while
he'll help you but he always revert
right back to his conman ways to
compulsion he can't stop it let's see
here's your money back one two three
what and I don't think I'm a bad guy but
it's really fun to play bad guys he grew
into the character and as he started you
got more mannerisms out and you started
gesturing more and making like faces and
hand shapes that look like it goes with
my apron
my name is Zelda Williams and I will be
voicing Amaya Blackstone in the new
King's Quest what a glorious day for a
tournament my favorite time of year
Amaya is the blacksmith and Daventry
it's just like a no-nonsense like what
are you worrying about Graham should
just go and solve the tasks go do it
what that sack lunch down yeah yeah I
can't be a fan of anyone that connected
with their emotions hang out a sake
Graham right I'm reading the part
you'd be surprised that the information
people give out when they're too busy
thinking about their own agenda my
character and this is the clever one so
I enjoy that part without you no one
could have made it across well-done
Graham I'm a on the chip and I thank
Queensland you faced a dragon you made
weird new friends you battled for wits I
just don't get it being the voice of
Gwendolyn is really cool because you're
in a video game instead of being in a
movie which I'm usually been in I get to
be part of a game and pretty cool so
I've just got to know what's brewing in
that cauldron is it a Transfiguration
elixir is it an invincibility potion if
I drink it will I understand the
language of creatures my name is Josh
Keaton and I play young king Grey what
an entrance ticket from my work I think
he's pretty heroic he's the hero of the
story he is probably the greatest
character in all of King's Quest lore
and a fixture and a pillar of Daventry
Daventry has been an interesting
experience so far honestly I'm starting
to wonder if it's for me can I pet your
goats a shield uh-huh it's been a lot of
years since a new King's Quest game has
hit the market and been out there yeah I
mean it's an old franchise - it's about
30 years old now so it's older than I am
I mean these are classic games and so
many games after the fact have really
just been an evolution of what Sierra
games brought to the forefront I love
adventure games and puzzle games
especially were my childhood and I'm
really glad that they're games that are
bringing that back you don't have to be
aware at all of any of the previous
versions of it this is a great entry
level starting point to King's Quest I
think once you blast into that world
where there's
Knights and goblins and unicorns that
are really goats with horns rubberband
into their heads it's just you're there
well the new added or not LM are old it
has an excitement to it that appeal to
them whatever they come from I'm
personally so proud of what we've been
able to create it's one of those games
that you drive home and you're just
thinking about wow I can't believe you
actually get to do this every day